here we go so yeah as Michael said I'm a
principal research scientist at the
Wikimedia Foundation I've been working
there since about 2011 which was
actually about halfway through my PhD
just doing a little bit of contracting
work with them and then eventually
becoming a full-time staff member this
by the way is my my profile page on
Wikipedia and so that's why I'm showing
you that so before we get into what I
want to talk to you about today I want
to give you a little bit of context so
planet Earth about seven billion people
this data is actually from March 2012 so
a little bit more than the figure that
you see up there the number of Wikipedia
readers on a monthly basis is about 500
million so that's about one in ten but
one in ten people planet Earth read
Wikipedia at least once a month
but the number of people who edit
Wikipedia is about a hundred and ten
thousand and that's about a one to ten
thousand relationship and I want you to
know there actually is a dot right there
it's kind of hard to maybe see from the
back of the room and you should know
that that dot is actually way too big
it's really hard to make a dot that's
smaller than a pixel on a pixelated
surface and so you should just know
that's really tiny dot for a reason so I
wanna zoom into this little area quick
and show you a little bit about what's
going on right here so the number of
people who edit Wikipedia I I showed you
before is about a hundred thousand
editors the number of people who work at
the Wikimedia Foundation is about two
hundred and fifty people this is 225
back in 2012 but it's grown very slowly
over time and we're about one to one
thousand with a number of volunteers who
are working on Wikipedia so we're a very
very tiny organization for something
that's relatively big at least sort of
global scale so the research at the the
research team at the Wikimedia
Foundation is actually about six people
and you can sort of compare this to like
we're about the same size at least as
far as traffic and interest from the
internet as Google google has I actually
have no idea but I would guess that it's
more on the scale of maybe six hundred
people in their research group and so
you'll notice that I'm not actually
listed along with the other researchers
here because I sort of started a
spin-off team within the same
organization called the scoring platform
team I'll tell you a little bit more
about what that means
later but essentially I have a couple
engineers who are working with me on a
specific project that we're we're going
to talk about today
okay so on to the actual story that I
want to tell you and so if you don't
give many presentations I'm gonna give
you a pro tip right now and that's you
should have three things in each of your
presentations it doesn't matter if you
actually have three things to talk about
it you should just pretend that it's
three so first I'm going to talk to you
about
Wikipedia's the socio-technical system
I'm gonna bring in a little bit of
systems thinking and biological
metaphors then I want to talk to you
about this critique of the quality
control system in Wikipedia which is the
story that Michael is just telling you
about but I'm gonna pull in a lot of the
stuff that wasn't in my thesis to talk
about like how I think Wikipedia got to
this place I'm gonna bring in a little
bit of feminist theory with standpoint
epistemology and I want to talk about
the way that we encode our ideologies
and the technologies that we build and
then finally I want to talk to you about
infrastructure for socio technical
change
I'll introduce this term as a progress
catalyst and I want to talk to you about
the dangers that we can get into around
having algorithms operate in social
spaces and how we might actually be able
to design to mitigate those problems
okay
so part one the socio-technical of
wikipedia so let's start off with what
is Wikipedia anyway
well obviously it's an enormous
encyclopedia it's the world's largest
arguably with about five and a half
million articles in English Wikipedia
and I was just in Rio giving a talk
about this and so I wanted to include
that there about 1 million articles in
Portuguese you know it's just enormous
this is something that you probably
already know so it's obviously also a
wiki and a wiki is an interesting thing
because it's sort of it flips the
publication model where you publish
first and review later this is totally
strange compared to how every other type
of publishing system works and beyond
that in Wikipedia anybody can edit and
we share authorship and so there's
actually a policy in Wikipedia against
stating or behaving as though you own an
article you have to share authorship
with other people they have to be
allowed to edit the article too it's
also an online community I was telling
you before there's about a hundred
thousand active editors who are working
in this space they do a lot of the
things that other online communities do
like set up forums so in English
Wikipedia they call their forums village
pumps and so for example they have
one for discussing policies one for
discussing technical issues proposals
etc they also have subject matter
interest groups so for example wiki
project videogames focuses on making
sure that the articles in Wikipedia
about videogames are high quality same
thing with wiki project medicine for the
articles about medicine there's lots of
these so but I'm a computer scientist
and so when I look at Wikipedia I want
to put it in terms of a system a system
with inputs and outputs in this case the
input is available human attention and
the output is Encyclopedia material this
is really cool for me because I can talk
about the efficiency how much output are
we getting per unit input so how much
encyclopedia material are we getting
based on the same level of available
human attention and so I want to make
the argument that Wikipedia is a socio
technical system and in order to do this
I wanted to find this term so to define
this term I want to talk to you about
the history of socio technical systems
from my point of view so when computer
systems were relatively new they mostly
would appear in an office setting you'd
have like a dumb terminal hooked up to a
mainframe it would allow you to do some
things like maybe set up the payroll
system or something like that at an
organization and really we would see
social things happening next to
technical things these technical
computer systems but after a while we
realized that we could actually start
doing some of those social things with
the technical things so at the very
bottom of the screen here I have some
very old calendar app and a very old
mail app and so these were examples of
where we could help out communication we
could help out scheduling getting people
to the same place at the same time using
technologies and so we realized that
technical can support social interesting
but when I say socio technical I'm
talking about something that's much more
tightly integrated than that and that's
the space that I think that Wikipedia
and a lot of other online communities
and technical systems actually operate
and so I'm a technologist but for just a
minute to make this point I'm going to
pretend to be a techno biologist
anyway biologists in the room alright I
can get away with murder
okay so on the screen I have for you a
couple sketches that I've made these are
actually up on Commons open license if
you like them
so of a bacterium and a Paramecium so
this bacterium is way too big it's
really important that I explain that to
you if you were biologists you would
look at this and go well that's not to
scale because a bacterium would be so
smaller to actually be smaller than
those little bits of poop that are
coming out of the Paramecium right there
you would barely be able to see the
bacterium next to the Paramecium and
what I really want to convey to you
right now is that these two
single-celled organisms operate at
massively different scales bacterium is
really really simple it's basically just
like a little sack of salt water it's
got some DNA floating around in it
there's some little specks in it these
ribosomes that help transcribe DNA to
proteins and then I guess there's
there's a few vacuoles which are these
sort of like little fat bubbles but
really nothing very complicated they're
really just a little little ball of salt
water but a Paramecium is a massively
complex huge thing it's got really cool
things like two different nuclei it has
this really cool thing called a
contractile vacuole which is how a
Paramecium can survive in freshwater
environments if you know anything about
osmosis you'll know that if you take a
freshwater sac of water and you put it
into our sorry a saltwater sack of water
and you put it into a freshwater lake it
will explode because all the water what
kind of wants to come rushing into the
salty environment the way that the
Paramecium deals with this is it has a
pump there's actually that that
contractile vacuole is constantly
pumping whenever the Paramecium is in
freshwater and that's how it survives if
that pump ever shuts off it'll explode
so when I think about Paramecium and a
bacterium I think about social systems
and the scales in which they can operate
and so at the bacterium end of the scale
we have a small fishing village you know
less than a hundred people maybe 150
people and at the scale of Paramecium we
have something that's like a city
hundreds of thousand maybe millions of
people or something like Wikipedia which
operates at that kind of scale so has
anybody here ever heard of Dunbar's
number yeah right I don't usually get
that many people when I give this kind
of talk who have heard of Dunbar's
number but I appreciate that you have
because I think it's really cool so
Dunbar was a social scientist I don't
know if that's fair to call him that but
anyway he was a research
who is studying populations of people
and he was looking at fishing villages
like the photo that I have on the screen
right now and one of the things that he
noticed is that a fishing village
generally doesn't get above a hundred
and fifty people whenever it does get
about a hundred and fifty people it'll
have sort of like a civil war and a
group of people will leave the fishing
village and go start a new fishing
village and so he was he was wondering
like why this upper bound of about a
hundred and fifty people and I think
what Dunbar was running into is that if
you have a group of people without the
infrastructure to allow them to operate
at a larger scale the the largest scale
that they can operate just using their
relationships with each other is about
one hundred and fifty we're on
Wikipedia's into the scale that's where
we're getting into these interesting sub
structures and so before I move on I
want to make this point really clear
about like when I say socio-technical
I'm talking about how the social which I
would put in the case of this Paramecium
which is basically if you try to imagine
a Paramecium that was just a sack of
salt water that's sort of like saying a
large group of people with nothing to
support them in this case I have a photo
of Wikimania one of the the yearly
conferences that we have for Wikipedia
stuff and then in the critical
subsystems that allow it to operate at
scale in the case of the Paramecium
these organelles but in the case of
Wikipedia technologies like media wiki
policies guidelines and rules and robots
and tools that people build in order to
make the system come together in
function and so when I say
socio-technical and I'm talking about
the merge between social and technical
I'm really actually talking about this
Paramecium that if you were a biologist
and you were studying this Paramecium
you couldn't just study the saltwater
sack separate from the organelles and
understand what's going on with a
Paramecium you have to study them
together in the same way that if you're
studying Wikipedia you have to study
social processes and the technologies
that enact those social processes
together in order to understand what's
going on at all so that's what I mean
with socio-technical and now I want to
talk to you about the specialized
subsystems of Wikipedia because I think
Wikipedia only operates at the scale
because it has these specialized
subsystems so I'm gonna split these into
five these are just the way that I view
things they're not any and there there's
no truth to this I just think it's a
useful lens so if you're a Wikipedia and
you're gonna operate at scale the first
thing that you need to do is
alakay work we can't have everybody
working on the same thing it would be
better if we had people working on the
the most important things first in
Wikipedia we should write the article
about chemistry before we write the
article about Breaking Bad actually
that's sort of up for debate because
Breaking Bad is very popular so we
largely get this for free due to Linus's
law and when I say Linus's law I'm not
actually talking about the Linus's law
that was formulated by Linus the Linux
kernel developer developer I'm talking
about the Linus's law that comes from
Eric Raymond another open source
luminary which is stated simply given
enough eyeballs all bugs are shallow and
so what Eric was talking about is that
in open source context if you have a lot
of people look at a problem like maybe a
bug in a piece of software for one
person they're gonna be able to see oh I
can fix that bug really easily I know
exactly what's causing this they're
gonna be able to see into the system and
be able to fix it and so the critical
insight in here is that visibility is
critical to open collaboration that when
you when you have a bunch of people who
can work on something and they can see
what's happening they can see the
problem see the potential contributions
then you can sort of optimize the
situation where the right person will
find the thing that's easiest for them
to contribute to and so my corollary for
Wikipedia is that given enough people
see an incomplete article all potential
contributions to that article will be
easy for somebody turns out that this
works in theory and by the way these are
citations in the right-hand side just a
little bit of what I think is useful
literature for understanding this it's
works in theory it's part of the process
of becoming a Wikipedia and we can
actually support this kind of visibility
with technological interventions like
recommender systems and really bad
things happen when we take it away which
we do accidentally sometimes wonderful
natural experiments ok on to the next
subsystem you're gonna have to regulate
behavior the entire Internet kinetic
Wikipedia you don't even have to
register an account we're gonna have to
form some norms we're gonna have to
propagate them and we're gonna have to
enforce them so if you search Wikipedia
governance in Google Scholar you're
gonna get a crapload of results Google
thinks that it's going to give you
37,000 results however that's not
exactly true because it's an estimate
but if you scroll down to page 10 which
I encourage you to do right now if you
want
check me on this you'll find out that
there's actually there's so much
literature about Wikipedia's governance
that you get to page 10 there's still
articles about Wikipedia and governance
structures so I just want to tell you
about how Wikipedians do this so let's
say that you have an idea for a new rule
in Wikipedia new norm well it might be
that you're you're prescribing something
like we don't do this and we should do
this or maybe you're just describing
something that already happens we've
been doing this thing this particular
way we should make a rule about that so
people know in the ways that we do
things and so those are two different
types of norms that Wikipedians like to
talk about so take your idea and write
an essay about it explain what it is
make a wiki page put it on put it on
Wikipedia not in the article space
there's other spaces for policies and
that sort of stuff and once you think
it's ready then you file a request for
comments and people will discuss the
merits of this this idea whether it
should be enacted as a rule or not if it
passes that threshold it becomes what we
refer to as a policy or a guideline if
it doesn't cross that threshold then it
just goes back to being an essay you
could do some work on it file and other
requests for comments or just leave it
as an essay so this sort of forms that
divide between informal and formal
policies in Wikipedia formal policies
being the actual rules and informal
policies being things that people talk
about in and share with each other but
aren't exactly formal rules and so I
want to give you a couple examples of
some informal and formal rules my two
favorites so my favorite informal rule
is don't stuff beans up your nose which
is actually not about putting beans up
your nose it's about not telling other
people not to put beans up there I was
because maybe they haven't thought about
that yet it's really don't tell the
Vandals not to do something they haven't
done because ha now they know to do that
anybody who has kids will know that if
you tell your kids not to put beans in
there no is there gonna be like wait a
second beans will fit my nose and then
they're gonna put beans in their nose
okay so example of a formalized rule is
verifiability Wikipedia is not truth
Wikipedia is verifiable I'm quoting
Jimmy Wales in this but I think it's a
really good summary of what this says if
Wikipedia tried to be truth the end-all
of truth the debates would never stop
and so instead what wikipedia is is
information that can be verified with an
external reference and this is I believe
what allowed Wikipedia to grow at the
rate that it has because arguments stop
on what you
in sight okay so fun story you can look
at these growth and regulations and see
some really interesting patterns this
this dark line on the top is the rate of
growth for new essays and the the dashed
lines of two different types of those
formalized policies those guidelines and
guidelines and policies those formalized
norms and the fun thing is that you can
see that in 2006 Wikipedia stopped
formalizing new rules at the rate that
it used to be formalizing new rules but
the rate of growth of essay writing went
through the roof and so there was
definitely a switch that was happening
here where people are doing a lot of
reflecting on what's going on in
Wikipedia but maybe not turning that
into new rules okay so now I want to get
to the quality control system if you're
gonna open a web page to the Internet
you're gonna have to identify and remove
damage obviously vandalism is a big deal
in Wikipedia so I think that mostly this
system like it gets a lot for free from
Linus's law that given it enough people
see an article somebody's going to be
able to see the damage in that article
and be able to fix it but in order to
operate at the massive scale that
Wikipedia has to operate Wikipedians
have built two types of automated
systems to help them manage quality
control at scale I like to separate
these into fully automated quality
control systems like clue bot in English
Wikipedia which uses a machine learning
model to detect vandalism in Wikipedia
it only works for obvious vandalism but
it's really fast it'll revert the
vandalism generally about 5 seconds
after it's saved for anything that makes
it past glue bots that will get picked
up when in one of the semi automated
quality control systems they also use
machine learning models so that they can
sort edits by the likelihood that
they're damaging so that people can
review the most likely to be damaging
things first it's still really fast
because with a semi automated system a
human computation system you can have
the machine do all of the work that the
human isn't good at and then just show a
human and DIF and ask them to make a
judgement yes or no is this is this good
or is this bad and most vandalism can be
caught at a glance so this works really
well and what's really cool about
Wikipedia is all these systems work
together the fully automated quality
control tools the semi automated quality
control tools and people just running
into vandalism as they're reading
Wikipedia it turns out that Wikipedia is
a bunch of tools that build slight
distributed
human tation structure so that nobody
has to talk to anybody to find out that
oh this person's been vandalizing
Wikipedia for a while and should be
reported to the administrators
noticeboard nobody actually makes the
decision I'm going to report this person
to the administrators notice board that
just happens automatically through
people using the tools in Wikipedia and
the fun thing is that together these two
strategies of reverting vandalism when
you see it and reporting vandals to be
banned from Wikipedia forms something
that I think looks like a lot like an
animal immune system with innate
characteristics which are fast general
and local that's you know you get an
infection say on your arm
it'll swell up because your immune
system is trying to attacked the local
problem it's really fast it'll happen
right away it works anywhere on your
body it's general however this adaptive
side and this is usually what we mean
when we say immunity is it's it's slow
it takes a little while to build up an
immunity it's specific to a particular
pathogen you've got to get this strain
of the cold the new strain of the cold
won't be picked up and its global works
across the entire system you're not
going to get a cold in your hand anymore
because you've dealt with the cold all
over your body and this is like banning
vandals in Wikipedia I don't think it's
a coincidence that Wikipedia strategy
for dealing with pathogens looks a lot
like animal biology is strategy for
working and dealing with pathogens okay
so on to community management we're
gonna get a bunch of newcomers arguably
the most newcomers that any organization
has ever got and on a daily basis we're
gonna have to socialize them we're gonna
have to train them and we're gonna have
to deal with disputes that people have
so Wikipedia gets 6,000 newcomers a day
is there any other organization in the
world that gets 6000 newcomers a day I I
don't know like it depends on how you
define organization right so we've got
to route them so we have a tool called
host bot in English Wikipedia the job of
this bot is to identify newcomers who
are obviously vandals and basically just
leave them alone because we already have
ways of dealing with them but find the
people who are obviously not vandals and
route them to newcomer help spaces like
the tea house which is a question and
answer space for new editors to get help
with dealing with the complexities with
Wikipedia when they first show up
finally I want to talk about a system
that you might not have guessed which is
the reflection and add up
patience system of Wikipedia Wikipedia
is no centralized governance system so
Wikipedians as a collective needs to ask
and answer questions like where are we
going where do we want to go and how do
we want to get there so I was showing
you before about how Wikipedia's
governance system works and I was
showing you the rate at which new
policies were formalized I think that
formalizing policies are very clearly an
adaptive process whereas writing essays
are very clearly a reflective process
where people are asking questions and
thinking about what should happen and I
think it's maybe concerning that it
looks like Wikipedia is not adapting as
fast as it used to be despite the fact
that it still does have some problems
which I'll be telling you about in a
little bit so coming back to why I gave
you this biological metaphor in the
first place is that I mean if you were
to look at a Paramecium and see it as
you know a sack of salt water or maybe a
collection of chemicals just running
into each other you wouldn't get the
whole picture and it's really important
that you actually look at the whole
thing in order to understand what's
going on with the Paramecium in the same
way when you look at what's going on in
Wikipedia the kind of problems that it
has you shouldn't just look at the
immediate context of that problem you
should ask yourself how does this whole
system enact this problem and how might
the whole system interact enact a
solution how can we get the people in
their culture the tools that they're
using the bots that people develop to
change in a way that will make the
system work better to be more efficient
to get excuse me more output per input
more encyclopedia material per human
attention okay so on to the critique of
algorithmic quality control systems
let's dig into how one of these so one
of these subsystems is going a little
wonky so this is the graph that Michael
is telling you about actually it's not
even an updated version of the graph
it's actually the exact graph that comes
from this paper that I have a citation
for you here I want to just walk you
through the the results of this paper
using this graph really quickly and help
you get some context for what
Wikipedians were experiencing so this
graph shows you the number of active
editors who are working on Wikipedia on
a regular basis over time so in the
early days of Wikipedia leading up til
about 2004 most of the infrastructure of
Wikipedia most of the subsystems were
formed by humans and practices they
didn't have a way of formalizing rules
they didn't have very many BOTS that ran
on the system they didn't have a
algorithmic tools health and with
quality control it was really just
people forming the basic infrastructure
of Wikipedia Wikipedia was a lot like a
fishing village at this time but between
2004 and 2007 I like to refer to this as
the exponential growth period everything
turned into a firehose suddenly there's
there's thousands of newcomers showing
up thousands of new pages being created
every every day and hundreds of
thousands of new edits to articles that
we already have we have to deal with
this and deal with vandalism and damage
and that sort of stuff and so
Wikipedians made quality control tools
that I told you about before like Huggle
which is one of those semi automated
tools and clew bots which is one of the
fully automated tools to help them deal
with this issue that all happens during
the end of the exponential growth period
and I want to talk to you a little bit
about like the key technologies that are
inside of these tools so the key
technology that I see is the machine
classifier essentially what this does is
it takes a bunch of statistics about
what happened in and edit like was the
person who saved the edit anonymous how
many words that they add from a bad
words list like racial slurs and curse
words repeated characters are really
common like people like to vandalize
Wikipedia by going KKK KKK KKK I don't
know why but it'll just like fill an
entire line with the letter K and so
these statistics will go into the
machine learning model the machine
learning model will figure out some
correlations between those statistics
and if an edit is vandalism or not and
then it'll be able to make a prediction
using some hidden strategy for doing
that and the really cool thing is you
can take one of these machine learning
models and you can take the firehose of
a hundred and sixty thousand edits that
English Wikipedia gets every day and you
can split it into the ten percent of
edits that need review and the 90
percent of edits that don't need review
so just to put this into some numbers
and people for you so without machine
prediction reviewing a hundred and sixty
thousand edits per day if you've stayed
up all night and you drank a lot of
caffeine and you didn't go to the
bathroom would take a hundred or two
hundred and sixty-seven hours and that's
about thirty three people working eight
hours a day without a break but with
machine prediction we can cut that down
to sixteen thousand edits per day still
a large number but that would only take
about 27 hours somewhere between three
and four people spending eight hours a
day looking at this
and so this was a massively useful
technology for allowing Wikipedia to
operate at the scale during this
exponential period so moving on in the
story something went wrong during this
decline phase we see an abrupt change
from an exponential growth period to a
relatively steady decline so the big
question that I was dealing with in this
work was what the heck happened there
like how did this happen there were a
bunch of hypotheses at the time we might
get to into some of those in the
questions but I want to tell you about
the hypotheses hypothesis that I think
has still failed to be refuted many
years later but in order to tell you
about like what I think was going on
here I want to talk to you about what it
Wikipedians were experiencing at the
time and how we can see them encoding
their experience in view of the world
into the technologies that they built
here in order to do that I want to talk
to you about these terms standpoint and
objectivity in order to do this I'm
gonna be challenged channeling one of my
favorite feminist scholar is Donna
Haraway Donna Haraway was a researcher
who studied scientists who were studying
apes an ape studying ape studying Apes
and so so what she did is she split the
scientists the the research lab that she
was looking at into two groups the the
male scientists and female scientists
and I put a star next to female
scientists because really what she was
looking at were research groups that
were very patriarchal in their structure
and research groups that were sort of
informed by the feminism critique of
patriarchal structures at the time so
these are two two discrete groups of
scientists who are looking at the exact
same thing the exact same observations
of a behavior yet they asked really
different questions learn different
things about what was going on with a
behavior the patriarchal scientists were
really interested in evolutionary
patterns so they asked questions about
reproductive competition and dominance
you know which Apes had sex with which
other apes and how was that organized
within their social structure whereas
the female or feminist scientists
instead ask questions about
communication and social grooming like
how do social circles form in a behavior
so now back to defining these terms so a
standpoint gives you a view of what's
important and valuable in the world do
you wanna answer question
about communication patterns or do you
want to look at dominance patterns in
sexual selection your objectivity is
what you construct in order to reify
this value in the case of the scientist
these were the methods were they
measuring grooming patterns like
literally recording in a notebook like
when did this ape groom this other ape
and how often does that happen and when
does it happen or were you looking at
sex partners same notebook write down
like oh this ape had sex with this other
ape okay interesting let's put that into
the data set so that's the objectivity
how you reify this value but the really
critical insight that Donna Haraway had
at the time and I think that we benefit
from now is that standpoints and
objectivity z' can be merged neither one
of these questions or views on what was
valuable is inherently better than the
other and we actually benefit from
merging the two together and so if you
were to look at a text book on a
behavior right now you would learn
something about both reductive
reproductive competition and
communication and social grooming
patterns the fact that we had people
looking from different point of views
and thinking about different things is
valuable turning those into different
methodologies to answer different
questions benefits us with a broader
understanding of a behavior okay
so let's pull that back to Wikipedia and
talk about the standpoint that people in
Wikipedia had during the exponential
growth period so at the time they see
holy cow Wikipedia is become a firehose
we need to revert the bad edits as
they're coming in Wikipedia into
Wikipedia and we want to minimize the
effort that we waste doing this quality
control work we don't want to spend two
hundred sixty seven hours every day
wasting you know reverting vandalism so
the objectivity the thing that they
brought about in order to reify this
value were the technologies that they
put in place in the time based on
machine learning models that were able
to reduce their workload dramatically
and this was a massive success and so
right now you can sort of look at like
the Internet has a firehose going into
Wikipedia that firehose gets filtered
through these quality control tools that
reduce the workload by about ninety
percent and then it actually makes it to
Wikipedia that's not quite right because
it's published first but it's really
hard to draw a diagram with loops so
let's think about it that way so it
wasn't until 2009 that somebody was
looking at a graph that was very similar
to this and said whoa holy cow we're not
growing exponentially anymore we're
actually
declining now and it's not the
experienced editors that are leaving and
getting tired you know they had a
Wikipedia for a while now they're bored
they go do something else
it's the newcomer Ernest the ones who
are showing up really excited want to
edit Wikipedia they're not sticking
around anymore
this was Bob Watson and his
collaborators at Palo Alto Research
Center singularity is not near one of
the critical bits of literature about
Wikipedia so it took us a while to
figure out what the heck was going on
because there were a lot of hypotheses
that were going on in the space like
maybe Wikipedia is running out of stuff
to write about or maybe Wikipedia
shouldn't be that big and it's actually
just shrinking down to the size that
really ought to be it took us until
about 2012 for us to realize holy cow in
in the standpoint that we brought to
developing the technologies and
practices that we put in place we forgot
about the value of socializing the
newcomers it turns out that when you
split the 160,000 edits that are coming
into Wikipedia the vast majority of the
stuff that needs review and is maybe
damaging is actually newcomers who just
aren't quite getting it right - their
first time editing Wikipedia it's
actually a tiny little fraction of that
bad stuff that's actually vandals who
are trying to bring harm to Wikipedia
yet they're lumped into the same bucket
they're actually sent the exact same
warning messages stop analyzing
Wikipedia we're gonna ban you and so by
making the sub system for quality
control boost it and much bigger and
much more powerful it actually ended up
sort of squashing the community
management subsystem of Wikipedia and
Wikipedians ended up throwing out the
baby with the bathwater quite literally
so hey
now that we know this maybe we should
also value newcomers having a good
experience and design for that great so
let's review our standpoint we're gonna
extend it so so Wikipedia is still
firehose that's still true about its
need to be reverted mhm and we would
like to minimize the effort wasted on
going and doing quality control work but
yeah now we actually also want to
socialize and train the newcomers great
so in the time period between 2012 and
2015 and I'll explain why I'm talking
about 2015 in just a moment the
conversation around Wikipedia
incorporates this new standpoint so
there's a major foundation or wikimedia
foundation goals around encouraging new
newcomers to stick around and continue
to edit wikipedia the newcomer helps
spaces like the one that i talked about
the tea house was developed around this
time to make it easier for newcomers to
get around the complex rural structure
that Wikipedia has so win right you know
like we extended our standpoint we got
new objectivity is is great
well so it turns out that this this part
of the system the filtering part of the
system that stands between the internet
and Wikipedia didn't really change that
much and I wanted I'm gonna pick on one
of the quality control tools here but I
want you to know that this story
actually applies to all of the quality
control tools that are in this space so
I'm gonna pick on Huggle so before I get
into the critique I want to start with
the sugar I give this kind of talk a lot
to people who develop these tools and
it's important that you don't tell them
that everything is bad and I want you to
know that everything about Huggle is not
bad Huggle is actually an amazing piece
of software and I have no doubt that it
represents the state-of-the-art and
distributed quality control I talked to
people at Facebook Google
pora about how they do quality control
and they're ten years behind us like
Huggle is what they have it's not Huggle
but it looks exactly like Huggle this
software and its users are responsible
for critical work without them Wikipedia
would have totally tanked a long time
ago its developers and its users are
wonderful people I know a lot of them
personally and we owe a lot to them like
we do because we benefit from Wikipedia
so let me take this opportunity to say
thank you to them now this is now the
medicine so in 2009 when we first
figured out that Wikipedia was declining
this is what Huggle looked like so you
can see there's like a pain on the
right-hand side here it shows a diff two
versions of an encyclopedia article with
the changes that happen there in this
case somebody was removing the text she
smells like bad body odor and so this
was actually somebody was cleaning up
vandalism here and so this was a good
edit and so in order to do something
about this I would click one of these
two buttons in the upper left hand
corner here there's a bad button that
reverts it and sends a warning message
to them and a good button that actually
just does nothing it just moves you on
to the next edit that there's no like
hey thanks for a good edit or anything
like that that comes out of clicking the
good button on the left hand side here
we have edits sorted by the probability
that they're damaging based on that
machine learning model so that you
review the stuff that's probably bad
first and review the probably less bad
stuff later so and in 2009 we had this
big revelation that newcomers were
getting hammered by these kind of tools
so in 2015 there was a major redesign of
the Huggle software and I talked to the
developer of Huggle quite a lot about it
like the problems with the software did
with how people use it how it wasn't
designed for these sort of things and so
I want to show you how the software
changed so you can see there's still
this sort of diff pain we're showing two
versions of the article with the changes
there's still these good and bad buttons
at the top and there's still this list
here of probably bad stuff - probably
less bad you know there's some rounder
corners and there's some gradients it
actually runs on more operating systems
they have a way better development
process and they did add a welcome
button but I would say this tool isn't
really designed to use that welcome
button and so as far as I can tell no
but he's actually clicked on that button
except for when they were running a test
so the tool isn't really designed with
newcomer socialization in mind but it
does have a button with newcomer
socialization in mind so the state of
the matter is that quality control in
Wikipedia is still not designed with
this in mind newcomers and especially
those who don't look like the people who
join during the first big wave into
Wikipedia remain marginalised you know
if you don't speak like them if you
don't value the same things that they do
then they'll see you as sketchy at least
different and needing review and so
we're still not seeing gains in the
retention of good-faith newcomers
despite the fact that we've we've
incorporated a lot of conversations in
this space quality-control is just the
first thing to hit you when you show up
at Wikipedia way before you get invited
to the tea house by host bot so why did
this happen why why did we adjust our
objectivity in other places but not in
the technologies that were developed to
do quality control work so why do we see
changes in some of the subsystems of
Wikipedia but not others so this is what
brings me into the third part of my talk
the infrastructure for socio technical
change what I think is missing from our
ability to change in the space so like I
was telling you before I think the
machine classifier is really critical to
these systems it uses statistics to make
predictions about which edits are good
and bad so the three main quality
control tools in Wikipedia are a Huggle
clue bots and sticky Huggle and sticky
solve a very similar problem but they're
both used at about an even rate so each
of these quality control tools has its
own machine learning model let's say
that you had an idea like you were
inspired by my talk and you're going to
and you're gonna write the next piece of
quality control software for Wikipedia
that's going to account for newcomer
socialization so you're gonna take this
extended standpoint and do something
with it
the first thing that you're going to
need to do is to build a machine
learning model that works in real time
in Wikipedia so in order to do that you
should probably read about 20 research
papers about Wikipedia damage detection
and if you're a volunteer developer for
Wikipedia you know like you're probably
wouldn't get actual practical machine
classification from your computer
science degree and honestly you probably
don't even have a computer science
degree most tool developers who are
working in this volunteer space don't
even if you had all those things
building one of these things and making
it work is extremely labor-intensive
they're massive performance
considerations and so you probably just
pull your hair out and give up so it
should be no surprise that all of these
tools all these three tools are authored
by computer scientists with extensive
skills and machine learning and
distributed systems sticky for example
was authored by one of the most prolific
author authors of Wikipedia damage
detection literature Andrew West so in
order to talk about what I think is
happening here I want to introduce this
reaction pathway graph that you might
have seen in a chemistry class
essentially what's going on here is
we're talking about like how much energy
do you have to put into a system in
order to have a chemical reaction take
place so imagine frying an egg
denaturing a protein is in exactly a
chemical reaction but stick with me so
if you wanted the transparent egg whites
to turn into actual white egg stuff then
you generally have to get it up to about
a hundred and fifty degrees Fahrenheit
but if you had a catalyst you know some
chemical that would make that reaction
happen easier then you could maybe fry
an egg at room temperature you wouldn't
have to put so much energy into the
system in order to get that reaction to
take place that's what's going on in
this graph so now I want to show you my
version of this graph which is progress
pathway graph and so I think that there
is essentially a reaction energy problem
if you want to get to the side of better
quality control and socialization you
first have to cross this mountain of
building a machine learning model that
works in real time and but if we had
some sort of progress catalyst some sort
of way to make this progress without
putting so much energy into it maybe we
would actually get a lot more people
crossing that mountain and so this is
what my team does I was telling you I
run the scoring platform team what we do
is we take this idea
machine learning model and we centralize
it because the all these machine
learning models that these different
tools are doing they're roughly doing
the same thing in different languages
using different algorithms but honestly
they're making the exact same prediction
and so they can all use the same central
machine prediction system and new tools
like host bought the one that wrote snoo
comers Snuggle is another one that
routes newcomers to help spaces can use
that prediction model too and so if you
have an idea you can also take advantage
of this centralized resource of a
prediction model to build your tool on
top of and so I want to show you a
little bit about how this works we call
this system ORS it's a data mining
metaphor so anyway so you can actually
open this URL in your browser right now
it's going to our machine learning
service so in this URL we're going to
ask something about English Wikipedia
we're gonna ask is this edit causing
damage to an article and then we give it
the number that represents the edit in
Wikipedia six three eight three oh seven
eight eight four and so in this case
this is an edit to an article where
they're fixing a link Wikipedians call
this link disambiguation they're making
sure that when somebody clicks on the
old woman in the page it goes to the old
woman the play as opposed to the the
page that says hey there's ten things
called the old woman which one do you
want so this is a good edit we have
scores to make a prediction about it or
it says Oh probably not damaging false
and I'm about ninety-four percent likely
that it's not damaging well let's give
it another edit so this six four two two
one five four one zero so in this edit
somebody removed a reference this is by
the way an article on dog intelligence
removing a reference replacing it with
llamas grow on trees all caps so we give
that to or as an or says oh wow yeah
that's probably damaging about 92%
likely that that's damaging and so it's
as simple as that you can actually open
this in your browser you can send a
native from Wikipedia and it'll make you
a prediction in pretty quick time like I
said it's pretty fast we're much much
faster than clue bot because it turns
out I have a background in computer
science I can do optimization for this
sort of stuff so we have medium delay of
about a half a second as opposed to five
seconds the whole system is scalable and
redundant if we get a bunch of
researchers who are using this for
research you should use this for your
research
then we'll add machines so that we can
handle the new capacity and because I've
read those research papers we can make
these models comparable to the state of
the art so essentially
what I hope that the system is is a
progress catalyst that reduces the act
and the necessary activation energy to
getting to better quality control by
about 20,000 lines of code and one
advanced degree in computer science and
honestly I've been working on the system
for about three years now so probably a
lot of hours on top of that and so my
hope is that then we'll get a lot more
people experimenting in this space using
this extended standpoint experimenting
with new objectivity 'z that reify this
value of better quality control better
support for newcomers and fun story
huggles already cross that gap there's
been a lot of tools that have already
been developed in the space about 30 of
them there's been three major wikimedia
foundation product initiatives and
there's been a bunch of really cool data
science projects by the way you should
do research on this it's really cool ok
so I told you that there were three
things but I wanted to have this part
have its own section and so it's three
and a half feminist inspiration like how
we can use critiques of machine learning
and social spaces in order to change the
design of these systems so I want to use
this term subjective algorithms and I'm
borrowing this from zineb to Fekete that
subjective algorithms are algorithms
often aided by big data and now make
decisions and subjective realms where
there's no right decision and no anchor
with which to judge outcomes like what's
good what's relevant what's important
what's desirable and what's valuable and
actually I don't want to talk about
perspective API maybe we can come back
to that but in Wikimedia space we have
to deal with these questions all the
time whose end and depending on how we
answer these questions we can we're
deciding who's allowed to participate
who gets labeled bad-faith who has their
edits reverted you know who gets to
contribute to Wikipedia the machine can
really have a dramatic effect on these
sort of things so we have to be careful
so this machine learning model it's of
course not perfect in the case where it
says that something's good it's actually
going to include some important bad
stuff that it's going to make a mistake
about and when it says bad it's actually
going to include some important good
stuff and that it makes mistakes about
but the real problem is when we do
something more than that we actually
have a bias in place and so I'm going to
quote a Wikipedia editor about this
problem please exercise extreme caution
to avoid encoding racism and other
biases into the AI scheme and so
essentially what WMT is talking about is
like
say we built a model for harassment in
several discourse but for some reason
our the harassment side of our model
picked up messages from South Africans
because the way that they use English is
strange and so therefore ads more likely
to be harassment then we would be
silencing a group of people who are
already underrepresented on Wikipedia so
I want to tell you actually I'm going to
tell you one story because I don't have
time about how we detected some of this
bias in Wikipedia and how we dealt with
it so in this case I'm going to talk to
you about how we use the Italia or how
we picked up the Italian word ah and
actually we might have a little bit of
time so I might talk to you about it's
the how are you biased against anonymous
editors so the telling word uh which is
literally not a laughing matter so it
turns out that we deploy these things
for Wikipedians
and they they realize like oh wow this
makes mistakes sometimes we should start
recording those mistakes I didn't tell
them to do this they just realized that
this was an obvious thing that they
should do and so what I'm showing you
now is a screenshot from Italian
Wikipedia where they're discussing
specific types of mistakes that the
system was making on the very top you
can see rat punked telling me like hey
by the way we have a bunch of false
positives related to the Italian verb
for have so what was going on here
was that we don't just have bad words
like racial slurs and that sort of stuff
that we put into the model we also have
in formals such as informal SAR casual
speak that would not be welcome on the
article but would be welcome in a
discussion such as hello or hahaha you
can see where I'm going with this so
haha it turns out is a problem people
have analyzed in English on all of the
wiki's and so we use our English
language bad words and in formulas
everywhere it turns out that in our
informal lists from English we have a
regular expression that matches ha and
ha ha ha and that was catching aha in
Italian Wikipedia and so it turns out
that ha is laughing in English and AHS
not laughing in Italian so it turns out
that the once this was reported to us it
was a really easy problem to fix we
could just remove that one informal word
from use in Italian Wikipedia keep all
of the rest of the English informal
words and dramatically improved the
model we would have never seen that
unless people were auditing the system
for us yeah I think I can make it
through anonymous editors I want to be a
little bit quicker
this so apologies for going really fast
so it turns out we were getting a bunch
of reports that when people aren't
logged in and they're making edits the
system is flagging that is vandalism all
the time we should probably probably do
something about that
but maybe an ons are really bad maybe
they're actually just vandalizing all
the time
generally anonymous editors are twice as
likely to be vandalizing Wikipedia
however 90% of their edits are good so
we should probably not flag all them as
bad so it turns out that you can use ORS
and inject features into it and so you
can ask or something like if this edit
was saved by an anonymous editor what
would the score be if it was saved by
not an anonymous editor everything else
held constant what would the score be
and so you can find out that this
particular edit is 11.5% more likely to
be considered damaging if it was saved
by an anonymous editor but we changed
nothing else about the Edit ha ha or it
has a bias so you actually have to
change a few more of the features in
order to put this in place because you
know anonymous editors don't have a
registration date and all that sort of
stuff so I built three user classes and
tested out two different modeling
strategies to see if I could figure out
what was going on here one of the user
classes is anonymous editor one is a new
editor who just registered and the other
ones me epoch fail
so the two modelling strategies are a
great gradient boosting strategy and a
linear SVM strategy so this is not not
trying to affect the data at all just
looking at our test set so what we want
to see is that that not damaging edits
have low probability or squished up
against the left and the damage the
edits that are damaging have high
probability are squished up against the
right the other rate it's hard and you
know but we we see a little bit of a
weird thing under the linear SVM model
there's this weird bump of edits that
aren't damaging with a high probability
what the heck is going on there well
we're gonna figure that out in just a
second
so now let's ask the system how would
these graphs look if every single edit
was saved by an anonymous editor well we
can see something quite dramatic here so
under the gradient boosting model we see
that most of the damaging are not
damaging edits are up against the left
most of the damaging edits are up
against the right but for the linear SVM
model all of the edits are up against
the right with this super big spike at
about 80% likely to be damaging what the
heck well okay well okay that's for
anons what about for newcomers
that it's roughly the same story the
model learned roughly the same thing for
newcomers still the gradient boosting
model does a pretty good job of
discriminating between damage and not
damage even if it looks like every edit
came from a newcomer
however the linear SVM model still has a
very similar problem not quite 80% more
like 75% but still has this big problem
here all right now let's ask what if
every edit was saved by an experienced
editor like me remember I'm not changing
anything about the Edit just who saved
it it turns out that everything is
squished up against the left we
generally draw our thresholds at about
0.5 for likely to be needing review and
so that means that I can get away with
vandalizing Wikipedia muhahahaha this
was part of my design the whole time so
really this was a great problem to
understand and we didn't quite fix it
entirely as you can see in that last
slide
however we realized that a gradient
boosting strategy was just far better at
discriminating in these cases and it
wasn't so biased against anonymous
editors so we deployed that around
December of 2015 but it still needs work
there's still a bias against anonymous
editors and newcomers it's not gone and
so we've been digging into sources of
signal that have nothing to do with the
person who's making the edit and more to
do with the changes that they're making
such as hashing vectorization and
probabilistic context-free grammar as a
natural language processing strategy ok
so I just want to summarize the stuff
that I've told you today so in part one
we talked about Wikipedia is a socio
technical system brought in that system
syncing biological metaphors part to
talk to you about the quality control
system we talked about standpoint in
epistemology and how we're throwing out
the baby with the bathwater and then
finally in part three talked about how I
see this new system this new machine
learning system as infrastructure for
socio technical change this idea of a
progress catalyst and talk to you about
how we can address some of the dangers
of subjective algorithms by having an
open auditing space where people can
talk to us about them thank you
[Applause]
have the questions and discussion it
seems like you know a new perspective it
doesn't necessarily guarantee how those
you've been still believe like maybe
gays that believes that we need to have
newcomers I'm like no actually it's much
more important to Wikipedia x' overall
perception that we don't have incorrect
information so vandalism it seems like
you can essentially then the extant
power structure to essentially determine
you know I'm gonna block even if it's
eventually going to through all the
Wikipedia existence so just the fact
that we've all agreed that newcomers are
a problem yeah I feel like that's sort
of like saying you know racism is a
problem but it's still like the existing
sort of norms over power I have to try
and do something that might right how do
we actually make progress right and so
so like it would be very like I don't
like to use this term because it's like
whatever it's it would be very
patriarchal of me to show up and say no
this is important this is what we're
going to do and I know what to do and
we're gonna do this and I actually tried
that it was part of my thesis it was
that snuggle tool I was talking about
and mostly didn't work it people thought
about things differently because I made
a tool that was focused on newcomer
socialization but it didn't really get
adopted didn't really fix the problem so
a more more empowerment approach would
be to say like well I'm gonna try and
make it so that we're reducing barriers
so more people can participate in this
conversation and I really do see like a
technical innovation space as a
conversation like for example like take
take the app market when somebody makes
an app that does something new there's
only ten more apps that are taking
advantage of that thing well assuming
that it was good there's a lot of apps
that do something new and it was bad and
nobody cared about it and nobody does it
anymore but the really cool thing is
that you know just like am iam the the
concepts the design and affordances of
these apps will search and proliferate
and suddenly if it's such a good idea
maybe all the apps suddenly do it like
sharing things on Facebook we can debate
about how good of an idea that it is but
we'll certainly make you add revenue but
in this case what I'm really hoping to
do with this is open up the conversation
and so the my hope is that people who
couldn't enter the conversation before
will now enter the conversation but I'm
not able to say what they'll do when
they enter the conversation and so I'm
sort of making a bet that I think that
this problem is serious and I think that
talking about it openly brings brings it
will help people add that to their
standpoint their into their notion of
value but I really am leaving it up to
them about what they're going to do with
that what they're going to do with this
new entrance to the conversation and in
a way this is not great because they
could not solve the problem but in
another way like maybe I'm actually
wrong about what the real problem is and
somebody else will have an insight into
what the real problem is and now I've
still opened the door for them and
they're able to operate in this space
the space that they couldn't act operate
in before and so what we're seeing a lot
of is most of these tools that I was
talking about are not developed by
people with extensive computer science
backgrounds it turns out that Huggle is
about it's about 20,000 lines of code
and as soon as we deployed the service
somebody made a thing that does roughly
what Huggle does in about 80 lines of
JavaScript and so like it's phenomenal
like the difference that this makes for
like people experimenting in this space
and so we've seen like the conversation
definitely has expanded beyond the
people that were involved in it before
the types of people were involved in it
before but it's still a bet for what
they're gonna do with it my hope is that
either they're going to do what I hope
that they'll do with it or they're going
to do something that's actually better
than that that I was too stupid to see
minimalism for you
easily reject all edits from people who
have not been on Wikipedia or at least
three meters yes like basically closed
off all new signups huh and then you
know you start to open the fire up more
and more and I feel like at the end of
the day that conversation is how much
more work are you willing to do today in
order to benefit make socialization and
that's I think that has to be a cultural
yeah that happens across Wikipedia
I don't know how many these in a
decentralized organization like the
Wikipedia like that kind of cultural
shift that's like yep it's worth it to
us that we will like you know do more
work in order to support newcomers right
you know I I struggle with that too like
like it's much easier for me to look at
shifting the technology than it is to
shifting culture because like I mean
that's that's been an open area of study
for forever as long as social science
but my my bet is by like getting new
people in the door that's that's a
strong way to shift culture but I guess
like one thing that this benefits from
is at the end of the day we want
encyclopedia content and it turns out
like let's say that we just banned
anonymous editors I've looked into this
we would lose about 20 percent of our
productivity and so then you get to ask
the question is is doing quality control
worth 20 percent of productivity like
doing doing 27 hours of quality control
a day
and the answer like if I talked to
people about that and we computer
they're like oh yeah obviously and and I
think it's that way for for newcomers to
like people see that but the problem is
like you can't have a personal
interaction with everybody who shows up
in Wikipedia but we can do things with
ours and I've already been experimenting
with this for targeting newcomers who
are most in need of support the most
likely to be productive productive just
based on their initial excitement about
Wikipedia not the quality of their work
and the least likely to actually be
vandals who will just waste your time if
you try and go have an interaction with
them right now we don't have that and so
we're not even taking advantage of those
really those few but key places where we
could have a big effect and so that's
where I think technology could help
that's where I think like the innovation
space might move but you're right we
can't do everything but we can optimize
for the things that we've never been
able to optimize for before
try to achieve with an empowerment which
is leveraging the intelligence of others
and trans dialogue open source has been
trying to do that for a long time - what
do you think are the most significant
innovations so so like a lot of open
source is really about opening the door
but not paving the way so so in order to
work with this open source project you
might have to learn how make files work
and you're gonna have to learn about
this culture and you're gonna have to
learn about how to use a command-line
interface and that sort of stuff and so
I would say like this is much more
paving the way than it is just opening
the door you know anybody could build a
machine learning model and run about on
Wikipedia before this is much more like
building a bridge so that they don't
have to go through this terrifying
valley or over this huge mountain in
order to to do that sort of thing
and so like taken like considering the
the rest of the open-source world I see
something like Jupiter notebooks a lot
like how I see oars Jupiter notebooks
paves the way for people to learn data
science strategies among other things
that you can do with them but I think
that that's a really killer you use case
if you're not familiar with Jupiter
notebooks they're they're like a
web-based interface that allows you to
write say Python or our statistical
languages programming languages without
having to install anything like Jupiter
hub for example will let you run the
entire thing on a remote server you
don't have to learn about command-line
interfaces or installation dependencies
you can just open a web browser and
start writing Python and so you're not
you're not like paving the way entirely
it's not you can't just show up and be
like I am a data scientist you're gonna
have to learn Python you're gonna have
to learn statistical methods but there's
a huge amount of other crap that you
don't need to even start with before
before you get involved in in data
science and so so yeah that's where I
would draw the line between like oars
and Jupiter versus just open source and
open bug trackers and pull requests
so I've heard of hypotheses like like
about like these like cultural causes
for the decline of Wikipedia 2008 like
anything for example things like like
the rise of deletion ISM and like I like
that kind of thing
and Christie that's this could probably
be very easily studied in the context of
comparing different kinds of different
language Wikipedia's because the obvious
have different cultures is this like
it's like anything you yeah so a lot of
other Wikipedia is look exactly like
English Wikipedia especially German
Wikipedia German Wikipedia arguably has
a more deletion s quality focused
culture and they use these tools much
more aggressively towards new editors
and they have an even more aggressive
decline
whereas Japanese Wikipedia is much more
open much less focused on quality much
more like you know any sort of pop
culture topic is welcome to be written
about in the encyclopedia and they don't
have a decline that looks like this they
have they have something that looks much
more like an early late adopter curve
where it's like logistic growth that
flattens out it doesn't you know it
doesn't collapse over time and so yeah
we definitely see this in different
languages and there's there's a study
that I know is coming out soon that I
don't think is out yet that looked at
this like looked at this pattern of
focusing on quality control and then
having this decay of newcomer
socialization and therefore newcomer
retention across wiki --is which are
Mookie is sort of like a space for
hosting hobby wiki's so like the
Battlestar Galactica wiki and the star
wars wiki and that sort of stuff are in
this space and they exhibit very similar
patterns so it seems like this pattern
of focusing on quality and forgetting
about newcomer socialization is really
common you know what my hope is is with
this work we can maybe stop doing that
or at least make that shift lesser and
lesser we can still figure out how we
can optimize for all of it optimize for
quality control and still have newcomer
socialization and so maybe like new
communities won't go through such a hard
shift where they have this problem or
maybe even the old communities like
English Wikipedia might be able to
recover substantially all right let's
thank our speaker
you